hello when to welcome to this video
playing Cooney [ __ ] yeah okay I dare to
predict I'm going to win this game with
other than the tech yeah I'm sick of the
last games where nothing worked so i'm
going to just play a full scale attack
here and check made them
yeah so everything gets developed
normally have six hmm okay maybe it will
be difficult with the checkmate
Jan I don't like to cancel long in this
position but I probably have to I have
to come out please all right it just
this is one of those situations but that
I hate to no end you're getting a phone
call during a game and I have a score of
about zero yeah when when I get a phone
call during the game so i will lose this
game I'm sorry the initial prediction
was wrong I didn't didn't have the phone
call on my radar
yeah okay all fun set aside 94 m and
it's a problem Sutekh t5 prevent night
see for this way so 94 b 3 I mean night
a three bishop g six wins let's hope i
really hope
maybe that's something else I can create
five or something but don't see how that
should work
yeah maybe rook a true or something
crazy nope doesn't work I can take age
seven King age eight Queenie five wins I
hope should win I can figure it out oh
yeah no this is not working okay just a
second Queen age six check check that's
not made ok this is this would be a made
King g7 group g3 king of six don't don't
tell me that's not a maid I would be
extremely strange what are you thinking
about em okay so look here check
that's not checkmate here that would be
completely weird mini threatens
discounter made on c2 of course
I don't see you we near that that's
completely crazy hmm i have checkin p8
actually maybe that's that does the
trick Queenie 5 checking is 7 I can
actually interpose with the rook Wow
this is a mate but if i move my rook
it's not going to be a maid anymore so
can i maybe just move this rook just to
prevent the immediate check made
Queen age seven would be good but it's
made okay what I'm just gambling no I
didn't see a winner and I'm frustrated
probably there is no win it's kind of
strange but maybe there is really no one
[Music]
check
Queen d8 mate is this one idea would she
prevent it time morning ok
that probably was a somehow but again I
don't care anymore yeah queen bee three
em check okay and I have to then my age
porn has to somehow or do the trick
[Music]
check on the jeep own
and the ponds are not that easy to to
play against if he takes I'm promoting
[Music]
check check check
yeah I was a completely chilled game by
me but I simply didn't didn't want to
make a draw anything happen just check
check check check black forfeits on time
yeah i was extremely objectively very
bad what i did with that was just
frustrated yeah i'm sorry by the games
before somehow okay so it really is not
a nice site tour to analyze this because
it was just badly played yeah so here
green g 5 and 0 ke five already seems to
be extremely strong but it six cannot be
bad and now i played this one which was
of course risky quite quite clearly of
it ok ya b3 and route takes you two wins
Jeff Jeff just goes for for the attack
him check check yeah wins everything
okay until going back this something
like that yeah that's nicer air computer
finds all this quickly so it now takes
and it's really just to draw amazing
that I'm not able to checkmate here with
Queen and rook against the open king j
okay i can draw with ping Zhi 686 but
yeah I couldn't believe it yeah I rupee
one actually when I played is still a
draw objectively speaking ok Queen takes
d5 didn't even see that move check
so yeah minus 10 minus something check
check yeah and yeah this is a still and
this is still am at the age porn
objectively now a draw amazingly check
yeah the pawns are very dangerous by now
it gets critical for like slide edge
according to stop first yeah the g six
winning knight c6 saves what is the line
nights is 6g 695 okay and this kind of
thing I'm sorry jet check with the draw
etc yeah I mean now it's not I know it's
not easy yeah yeah until the chance
points then promote yeah of course
extremely lucky in a way but I knew that
I was last year the way out the way I
played but I just didn't want to make a
drawing I don't know it was a bit of a
tilt game which worked this time the
kind of game that if you are black here
I would curse to no end but yeah it
happens okay thanks for watching